hey guys dr. Burke here in this video I
want to share with you this really cool
little gadget it's the neck and back
self massage tool that I had created for
my own body so I can massage myself okay
it's designed after my own hand and the
different points that I do there's a
this is for an average person like my
size and you get a smaller person and a
real small person so it comes in a
tripod so you just set back on a tall
back chair or a couch and you lean back
okay and you let the massage tool hit
the points in the back now I just want
to explain and it's all explained in
this little booklet right here of what
to do the different points but I'll just
explain a couple little things one is
when you do you have the back of the
skull and then you have it's called the
occiput and it slides into the first
vertebra it's called c1 cervical one and
that's part of like the brain stem
sticking out there and there's little
nerve that help you go to sleep and the
center of those little nerve points what
is called a locus coeruleus and the
wrath I knew collide okay don't worry
about the names but they basically
trigger nerve points that help you wake
up and go to sleep
so they actually give you energy and
help you relax and go to sleep so I use
this before I go to bed and I just lean
back and I hit these points right below
the skull like the sweet spot and it
feels really good and you do that for
like two minutes okay and try to stay
awake because you're just like go to
sleep so it relaxes the whole spine
because all the like the fascia and the
the muscles and ligaments that attach
from the skull to the spine that seems
to be a tight area for a lot of people
so you want to reduce in that and the
whole spine just relaxes now as you go
down to the second vertebra that one
seems to open up the sinuses and all
those nerves that go to the sinuses come
right out that level too so it actually
helps you breathe better and then
because people have like a straight
spine they don't have the curve I like
to just slow
go down and find the tents the tight
spots of your neck and start to kind of
put that curb back in there and so I'll
just kind of work out lower lower until
I get to the very lower part now I've
done other videos on the different
points like the lower point is the
thyroid points and you can actually
improve circulation and some people that
will start getting warmer
not on everyone but some people and then
you can go up to the a little bit higher
and get the points in the vocal cords
I've done the before-and-after on that
and people with like hoarseness or even
laryngitis and making their voice tends
open up but overall it's going to make
your neck really melt and when the neck
is relaxed the whole body can actually
go into a nice relaxation so there's a
lot of different techniques you can work
on the Drina points you can work on
other stress points but the goal is to
pull as much stress out of your body as
possible so you can sleep good at night
and I bring this I travel with it I use
it every single night it's pretty cool
so you might want to get one and put
your comments below and I will see you
in the next video